reject nation welcome to the most speculative
episode of koi's comic corner to date this is all
stuff that i'm just theorizing having seen thor
love and thunder once and how i think that sets
up guardians of the galaxy 3 and what guardians of
the galaxy 3 might even be please do leave a like
subscribe hit that bell leave a comment i've been
loving reading what you guys are suggesting i talk
about on this very show and please do check out my
tic toc it's koi jondro for 15 second one minute
and three minute versions of this very thing
ranting theorizing comic recommending all of the
above thank you so much for watching let's talk
about what this magical experience sets up and a
thing that a lot of people on the internet aren't
discussing just yet so i personally think that the
end of guardians as we know them to date going
off into space in thor love and thunder mirrors
beautifully the moment in eternals at the end
where they go off into space to meet some gods i
don't know how this isn't the biggest conversation
for people that have seen the movies so far but
these movies literally have groups teams in
the mcu going off to meet gods that is a lot
of paralleling i think the eternals is vital for
phase four i think the eternals is foundational
for a lot of the things and i'm gonna get into a
tin foil hat theory near the end of this video but
i do think it is not a coincidence that we
last saw the guardians going off into space
and it seems like we've got the high evolutionary
as the villain of guardians of the galaxy 3 as
well as adam warlock so i think the plot might be
considering spoiler alert thor love and thunder
the guardians of the galaxy are simultaneously
trying to save gods as thor is and spoiler alert
thor accomplishes his goal he stops gore he does
not kill all the gods but we're hearing more and
more that there was a longer cut of this film that
was so violent that it would like you know walk
that r rating line christian bale has said that
there were things that had to be cut tyke has also
said the assembly cut of this film which is always
very long don't come at me snyder cut bros it was
like four hours doesn't mean that's a finished
movie doesn't mean we need the ytt cut this is the
cut he wanted but that does mean there is a lot
of things they couldn't include in this movie for
tone reasons that means somewhere out there the
guardians are preventing some of this carnage
pun intended he's not a god but he's a symbiote
out in space but i do think the guardians are
going to start the movie doing the task that
they said they'd be doing i think that might be
how we encounter adam warlock adam warlock is in
guardians one in a you know cocoon situation and
he's been teasing all these movies he's been cast
as the very very handsome will poulter confusing
people that don't know how puberty works will
poulter's been handsome now he's just shredded
but adam warlock is going to be i think discovered
while they're trying to save gods i think adam
warlock is going to be this very fish out of
water character that might help protect them
from high evolutionary or even help them in saving
these gods you need a very powerful character also
don't think it's a coincidence that our star-lord
is half-god i think that might come into play
remember he's the son of ego the living planet
there is a level of god to him he was able to
wield an infinity stone which doesn't get talked
about enough so i think that's all going to come
into play in him trying to save the gods we also
still don't know how gamora comes back into play
high evolutionary is a very complicated character
high evolutionary is theoretically our villain of
this movie he's been cast but we don't know how
he's going to be utilized obviously he basically
can evolve things rapidly he can try to make
things the best version of themselves and he
does that to the detriment sometimes of the thing
that might be a factor with gamora i don't know if
he's going to try to you know mentally manipulate
her i honestly don't know how they're going to use
high evolutionary because it's one a character i
will fully admit i don't know as well as others
there might be people in the comments right now
like that's not high evolutionary there's a lot
of interpretations he's not like kang in that
it changes because the writer because he can
travel through time he's like a 70s character
that someone thought high evolutionary was this
someone else thought was another thing because
that's a very vague concept of evolving things so
that's beautiful for james gunn look what james
gunn did with the suicide squad you've got a
foundation of madness you go crazy what better
villain what better character than a god golden
deity in adam warlock versus a thing that evolves
things maniacally a mad scientist gone awry to
deal with the chaos of the guardians of the galaxy
trying to save gods i think all of this conflict
is perfect and i do think the eternals trying to
save the celestials trying to do all of these very
very above god level things do tie together and i
do think the foundation of fastos tying everything
in together is going to be the big unifying thing
that makes phase 4 tick so imagine the eternals
are hunting celestials a form of god effectively
and the guardians are hunting literal olympian
greek gods to protect them also in spaceships it's
a small universe i do think they're gonna be both
on ships i do think we're gonna see those
teams interact and i do think it's gonna be
even if you don't love eternals it's always
exciting when teams come together comic books are
all about team ups and when they're teams of team
ups it's gonna be really special to see certain
characters interacting with certain characters
that's the fun of these movies that's the fun of
a shared universe two teams went out into space
it'd be kind of a waste if they didn't meet up
to save some gods together i think it's probably
inevitable and i think it'll also make for some
interesting commentary on what olympian gods
are versus space gods like the celestials what
moon knights gods are versus the pantheon gods i
do still think that was bossed at the pantheon i
do still think that was the avatar for the black
panther god and i'm wondering if by the time we
get to wakanda forever we find that out i wonder
if we meet her and go like oh that was an easter
egg i do think we're going to be getting into
more and more of the god elements especially with
the gin in miss marvel this is being shot before
episode 4 of ms marvel so in discussing the gods
and those elements of ms marvel honestly as of
now as of episode 3 i think the jinn are a mislead
i don't know if that means it's going to be cree i
don't know if that's going to be in humans i don't
know if it's just a different kind of underworld
but we do already have the field of reads and moon
knight and valhalla as well as other commentaries
and afterlife so gods are a very broad thing
i do think that's the unifying force of phase four
is the afterlife gods eternals those bigger than
life beings because we've had the street level
marvel we've had the celestial marvel i think
we're getting into deities marvel so i think what
happens to unify phase four is we see that fastos
maybe was the one that invented the ten rings
in chongqi maybe he was the one again haven't
seen episode four on yet that invented the bangle
in miss marvel maybe fastos has been doing things
on the ground floor of earth that caused a lot
of these things to tie into the gods themselves
and if you can tell things are going wacky and
70s and insane we're getting into very deep
jim starlin territory we're going full kirby with
these characters what better way to have guardians
of the galaxy 3 tie into the other elements of the
universe than the eternals making it all one more
cohesive thing so again tinfoil hat theory i think
fastos and the eternals and their connection to
the celestials tie into what we're about to have
in guardians of the galaxy three maybe even tying
into miss marvel i could be completely wrong you
could be watching this you're like koi two weeks
ago it was clearly the gin you're an idiot i don't
know yet but i think it'd be really interesting to
have two super teams come together and i do think
we're gonna have a lot of bloodshed with guardians
of the galaxy three i think the eternals
make it i think most of the guardians don't
i think in fighting the high evolutionary we
lose a lot of the team i think in trying to
save gods we might even lose a few members at the
top of the movie i can see this being a really sad
conclusion of the trilogy because james gunn loves
to kill characters he did the suicide squad for a
reason so i think guardians 3 a lot of bloodshed a
lot of high concept big larger-than-life visuals a
lot of things that do ground us weirdly back
into phase four and unify the whole thing
and they've also you might remember have a
christmas special in between so we're getting
guardians times two two different formats one in
disney plus and lots of other things that might
tie it all together and we're getting werewolf
by night before that which is supernatural more
god things and one thing i wanted to mention is
that singularity is the character introduced in
the last five minutes of thor love and thunder
and i gotta say having the title of the movie
be not a punch line but a an explanation the love
and thunder was brilliant but singularity herself
is an all-powerful being that is introduced in
a force which is an all-female avengers team and
then becomes friends of the kamala khan and
i think she's going to be used in the young
avengers she's not a young avenger in the comic
books but she is a team member again of a force
and i do think that using an all-powerful god
entity in the young avengers adds some stakes
i think as marvel goes more cosmic goes into more
of the god thing it allows us to have an anchor
with the young avengers having a young god she is
literally the singularity she is an all-powerful
being and as we see in the end she fights for
thor so i think while we have thor as a father
figure kind of maybe overseeing the young avengers
having his daughter be a god will tie beautifully
into guardians 3 will tie beautifully into all
the things i think we're getting to and give us
another member of the team that i don't think
anyone was expecting when you look at the young
avengers you've got certain expectations you've
got certain members we all thought kate bishop
we all thought certain characters singularity
is only in 23 issues of comic books check out a
force check out some of the ultimate stuff it is
a fascinating character that i think will be an
integral young avenger and maybe the biggest twist
we've been thrown from kevin feige setting up the
young avengers all of this could be completely
wrong my crazy theory hopefully you enjoyed the uh
the madness greg anything else so to conclude this
i usually give comic recommendations what's hard
about this is since i'm theorizing something that
doesn't quite exist in the comic books it's tricky
so i'd recommend checking out the bendis run
of guardians of the galaxy i'd recommend the
abnet run of guardians of the galaxy i'd also
recommend you check out the newest run of the
eternals that's still actually ongoing it's got
some of the most beautiful eternals art and it
deals with thanos so it feels a little bit more
approachable than a lot of the older kirby stuff
which is very esoteric and strange though lovely
and if you like the weirder side of marvel go back
and read the original kirby eternals because i do
think that kind of visual and that kind of holy
crap how does this exist is coming to guardians
of the galaxy three so strap in for marvel to
get even weirder with james gunn steering the ship
with high evolutionary adam warlock and maybe an
eternals team up on all that maybe tying in to the
ground level stuff we have today leading to battle
world secret wars and even bigger stuff and that's
another video thank you so much for listening to
me potentially rant about stuff that's not gonna
happen this was all a deep cut theory video please
leave a comment below let me know if you think i'm
just making sure well i didn't make [__] up but
if you think the [__] i made up was correct this
is all a theory of mine i could be totally wrong
argue with me in the comments i'll probably read
it get a little insulted but comment back just be
nice adjacent thank you to the real rejects
for giving me this beautiful place to have
harebrained tin foil hat theories thank you for
supporting the show and leaving comments with
suggestions of other things to watch other things
to comment on other things to make videos about
hit that bell so you can get notified of
other weird koi's comic corners of both the
streamlined and esoteric as this was i appreciate
you very much rejectation we'll see you next time